[Music]
good afternoon
and welcome to rockefeller university's
virtual science saturday
i am jeannie garberino director of rocky
to you science outreach
and your host for this afternoon's
program where i'm wearing my sign
saturday t-shirt this is the t-shirt
that we all wear when we have science
saturday on campus
and you'll see some pictures behind me
that'll be rotating throughout the event
to showcase some of the awesome stuff
that we
have had in the past and we will be
bringing back as soon as we can bring
science saturday
back to in person
first i would like to thank our generous
sponsors who have made science saturday
possible
they are the andreas c drakopolis family
science and society initiative
the quadrivium foundation the beset
freeman family
and the steinmann family foundation
before we turn our attention to the
amazing world of ants
i'd like to tell you a bit about myself
rockefeller university
and the work i do here i first started
realizing how important science was in
our lives
when i had to start taking care of my
younger siblings
i am the oldest of four kids and my
parents had two
uh baby i had two baby sisters come when
i was at age
10 and at age 12. so i'm 10 and 12 years
older than my baby sisters
and this meant i was big enough to
really help out my parents
sometimes i watched my sisters when my
parents had to go to the supermarket
or do some chores and i realized very
quickly
that humans had behaviors and those
behaviors can be linked to some sort of
cause like for example i realized that
when my sister made this
weird repeating cry it would be like she
needed a diaper change
and when it was when her cries were like
more groany it was like
and it also sounded a little bit like a
goat i
knew that she was hungry and it was so
much fun thinking about the patterns of
behavior
and it sparked so much wonder inside of
me and i wanted to learn everything
about science
so for years that's what i did i studied
biology in college where i figured out
that i wanted to officially train as a
scientist
and so after college i attended a
program at a university called columbia
and i got a special degree called a phd
this special degree allowed me to head
over to rockefeller
where i could do something called a
postdoc and do more studies and learn
about
how things work in more detail over time
i realized that i was super
passionate about teaching science just
as i was about doing science
which led me to becoming director of
rocky view science outreach at
rockefeller
this is really my dream job because i
can show students of all ages how
science is really
a part of our everyday lives and how
much
fun it is each school year my team and i
run lab programs for
thousands of new york city students in
grades k through 12.
we also work with teachers in k-12 too
students spend the day with us meeting
scientists conducting experiments in a
lab
just talking about science and during
the summer
we work with high school and college
students who paired with rockefeller
scientists who work on special research
projects
you can find out more about all of these
programs on our rocky d website
rockefeller is an amazing place to work
it is only
16 acres of land or for my fellow new
yorkers it
spans about four city blocks but it
feels like an amazing city
there are so many people who help to
make sure that the scientists and labs
can be supported
to do the best work possible this
includes anything from health with
taking care of our kids
to special health programs on campus
like vaccines
or use of resource center equipment and
expertise
and so much more there are about 600
scientists working
in 70 different labs researching almost
every disease or health condition you
can think of
it is an incredible group of people
smart
curious creative hardworking and
generous with their knowledge the
university was founded on the principle
of
science for the benefit of humanity we
follow that every day
in our lab work that same idea is also
important to
all of our science outreach programming
and science saturday is one of our
efforts to reach out to young students
and share the wonder and excitement of
scientific discovery
so i hope you're ready to explore up
close the amazing world of ants
i bet all of you have seen ants outdoors
in their natural habitat
i bet many of you have even spent time
studying ants
how they build structures to live in and
how they gather food
ants are just fascinating and their
behaviors lead to so many questions
how do these minute creatures organize
themselves to accomplish such
big projects are they always working
what do they eat we are extremely
fortunate to be joined by rockefeller
university's ant
expert dr daniel cronauer the stanley s
and sydney r schuman associate professor
and the head of the laboratory of social
evolution and behavior
daniel has been fascinated by insects
since he was in kindergarten
many of you might be in kindergarten and
you might be looking at ants right now
or maybe you looked at them yesterday
who knows as an adult
daniel likes to turn over rocks just to
see what kinds of insects or liver
living underneath daniel was born and
grew up in germany
and he received a degree in biology from
the university of wurzburg
followed by a phd from the university of
copenhagen
he joined the rockefeller faculty 10
years ago
at the university daniel studies ants
and the sophisticated
colonies in which they live ants by
nature are social
and prefer group living just like us
ant colonies are highly organized around
different tasks
to achieve this level of organization
ants need to communicate with each other
daniel will show us how ants communicate
with chemical
cues called pheromones during his career
daniel has studied ants from different
parts of the world
including army ants in costa rica in his
lab at rockefeller
he and his research group studied clonal
raider ants
which he is going to tell us about in a
moment when daniel is finished with this
presentation
we will take questions from the audience
we have some questions that are already
submitted
if you have a question during this
presentation please use the question and
answer function
at the bottom of your screen to type in
your question and we will try to get to
as many questions as we can
and now it is my great pleasure to turn
the program
over to dr daniel cronauer hello
everybody
i'm daniel cronor as genie already said
thank you for the nice introduction
genie
um welcome to science saturday um
so as gina already said i'm the head of
the laboratory of social evolution and
behavior
and we are a group of 12 people at the
moment and we all work with ants
and today i want to show you how cool
ants are of course and i will talk about
some of the cool things that they do
and so before we jump in i want to tell
you that there are a lot of different
ants and in fact there are more than 15
000 different types of ants
and just to put this in perspective this
means that there are more types of ants
in their types of birds and mammals
combined
and here are some of my favorites and
these are pictures that i took in
different
in different parts of the world and i
just want you one want
to run you through them that so you get
some feeling for how diverse ants really
are
so this here for example is a spider ant
from australia
and these ants are very elegant as you
can see and because of their spindly
long
legs they look a little bit like spiders
and that's what the name comes from
this here looks very different it's a
strobe and it's also from australia
and they are called strobe ants because
they run super fast and then they stop
and then they run super fast again and
then they stop again
so when you watch them it feels almost
like you know someone is turning the
lights on and off really fast so like a
strobe light
and that's probably also why strobe is
have such large eyes
because they have to be able to see
where they're running and they can't get
dizzy because they're running so fast
this here on the other hand it's an army
ant from the rainforest in costa rica
where we've worked
and these ants live entirely in the soil
so they're completely subterranean
and uh in the soil they hunt and kill
all kinds of insects and other small
animals and because in the soil it's
always dark they don't have to see
well at all and therefore they have
almost no eyes and they're blind so
they're very different from these stroke
bands
the one in the upper right corner here
is another type of army ant and i just
really like army and so i'm
showing you two of them and this is an
army and soldier with really long
mandibles
which are the jaws of the ants these
things here and they look like two
fishing hooks and these guys are really
good at biting people so when i go and
study them i always have to be careful
to not annoy them too much
and here's another ant with crazy
mandibles this is called a trap jaw ant
and the mouth of this ant works like a
mouse trap so when
a prey insect like for example a cricket
which they hunt
touches the little trigger hairs in
front of the ant they're hard to see
they're like these tiny hairs here not
these big things those are called the
antennae
these trigger hairs here the mandibles
they snap shot and they trap the cricket
and this goes so fast and with so much
power that the ant is propelled
backwards so they really fly backwards
with the cricket stuck in its mandibles
now here are two singing ants they are
from africa
i found them in kenya and they are
called singing ants because when they
are excited they stridulate
they make a sound that sounds almost
like singing by rubbing different body
parts against each other it's a little
bit like crickets or
cicadas things and these ants are
termite hunters and they come in two
sizes which you can see here the small
ants
like the one i'm showing here on the
bottom those go inside the termite nest
and they actually fight
and then the larger ants like the one on
the top here they carry
that termites back to their own nest as
food
and then finally here's anoth steka ant
and these ants they live inside the
hollow stems of trees
and in in return of having such a nice
house inside the tree
they defend the tree against animals
that like to eat plants
so you can get a feeling for that
they're really a lot of different ants
and they
do a lot of different things
but there are not only many different
types of ants there are also simply a
lot of them
and ants are really some of the animals
that people see all the time
even like here in manhattan you can see
them like running around on the sidewalk
for example if you went to tropical
rainforest and you put all the ants on
one side of the scale
that's you see here this little ant
looking out of the scale and you
take all the big animals like say
jaguars and monkeys but also the birds
and lizards
and they put all of them on the other
side of the scale the ants would be
heavier than all the big animals
combined
and the reason that the ants are so
successful
and so important in ecosystems is that
they are really good at working together
and of course if you want to work
together with others you have to be able
to talk to them
but ants don't speak with words but they
speak with chemicals
and these chemicals they're called
pheromones and each ant species has many
different pheromones and here i'm just
showing you
what some of these pheromones look like
but of course these are tiny
tiny molecules that you can't actually
see so those are just drawings of
like how we kind of think they might
look like
and the pheromones they are released
from glands and each ant has many
different types of pheromone glands in
different parts of our body
and each gland produces different types
of pheromones and so here i'm showing
you what an ant would look like if you
could see inside
and one thing you see is that there are
many many different glands and that each
one has a different name so for example
here in the head there's the maxillary
gland and the mandibular gland and the
propharyngeal gland and the
postpharyngeal gland
there's also the label gland that gets
released into the head
and then they also have a lot of glands
in the in the
back part of the antioxidant so there's
like the poison gland
and there's the rectal gland and the
sternal gland and the dewforce gland and
so on so on so many many different
glands
and when one ant releases pheromones
from such a gland the other ants smell
those chemicals with their antennae
that's
the front part here their little feelers
so when an ant releases pheromones she
sort of says speaks and when an ant
smells pheromones with her antenna
she hears and then by talking to each
other ants can do really cool stuff so
here for example
army hands in costa rica have built
themselves a house out of their own
bodies
and the walls of this house are
completely made up of the live ants
themselves
and the ants build by clinging to each
other with little hooks on their feet
and here you see them form chains and
these chains then become connected to
form the walls of the nest
now the army ants they live in colonies
with a million ants or so
so they're really really big and so the
colonies unfortunately so large that we
can only study them in the field so we
have to go to the rainforest in costa
rica for example to study them and we
can't bring them back to new york to
study them in the lab
but we have another species which is
called the clonal raider and
that we can keep in the lab and do a lot
of experiments with and today i'm going
to tell you a bit about how we're trying
to figure out how the clonal radar ants
talk to each other with pheromones
and one problem is that to us at least
of course they all look the same
but if we want to study who is saying
something and who's responding we need
to know who's who
so to tell them apart from one another
we put little color dots on their back
and that's what you can see here that's
why they all look like little painted
easter eggs
so this end for example maybe her real
name is janet but of course we don't
know
so we just call her green pink because
she has a green and a pink dot on her
back which we put on
and as you all know ants are of course
small so putting little paint dots on
them is quite a special art form
that you have to practice a lot and so
now i'm going to show you a short clip
where stephanie one of the researchers
in the lab demonstrates how this is done
so you see that she has like ant
colonies in these little
round things they're called petri dishes
and now she's taking one out
and she's looking at them on the
microscope
because the ants are of course small so
you do most of the things on the
microscope and now she has put the ants
into this bigger dish
and now she's taking them on out one by
one and she's putting them on this
little eraser rubber that's just like
one of these eraser rubbers you use in
school for example to
to erase like pencil marks and over
these eraser rubbers
she has like little nylon threads and
she can put the ant
under this nylon thread so then the ant
can't move
when stephanie paints her but of course
the ants don't like that so now you see
her close up like grabbing these ants
and the ants tried to run away but now
see she managed to put one under one of
these nylon strings
for the ants that's not painful the ants
have really thick cuticles like the
surface of the body is really thick
they're like little tanks so they don't
get hurt by this they
they they don't you know it's not
painful for them
but we have to strap them down like this
so that they don't run away and they
don't move so we can we can paint them
carefully
so now she's taking
it's like a permanent marker pen those
again are like permanent marker pens you
can just buy them any way you want
like some arts and crafts shop for
example and she makes like a little dot
with the paint and then she has a
little needle that's very fine and with
that needle she can take some of the
paint
and then she can paint a little tiny dot
on the back of the ant
now see the ant gets one dot on on her
butt
and then she gets another dot on her
back
like this and now the ant has two dots
one that's kind of green and one that's
kind of orange
and then when the paint has dried and
stephanie takes the ants off the rubber
and puts them back in their little nest
dish see
and you can also see that they're all
happy they're just walking around
and they're doing well there they are
and so they all have like different
combinations of these color dots so we
know exactly who's who here's green
green and here's
a green orange and so on and so on
but of course we don't only want to
paint our ants we also have to keep them
happy
and the ants they are a little bit like
our pets only that we have many
thousands of them in the lab
and so i'm going to show you another
video so you can see how we keep them
and how we feed them so here's again
stephanie
and she's going to the freezer and in
the freezer we have ant food
and now the weird thing is that our ants
actually in nature they hunt
other ants so they attack the colonies
of other types of ants and they steal
the brood from these ants so they steal
their larvae and
kind of their young and that's what they
eat so stephanie is feeding
our ants with the young or the brood and
the larvae and the pupae from
from other ant species and that's what
we keep in the freezer
and so here you can see all the ant
colonies that we have of the ants that
we work with
we keep them in these little tupperware
boxes like smaller colonies and smaller
ones and then really big colonies we
have in these very very big tupperware
boxes
so now stephanie is opening one of them
and see there's like a big
big cluster of ants in the middle
and that's where the ants kind of make
their nest and you can also see that in
the tupperware box we put
plaster of paris inside as kind of the
floor and the plaster of pears is really
nice for us
because it keeps moisture well our ants
they don't like it when it's dry it
always has to be really moist and humid
but the plaster can be hard enough so
that the ants can't dig inside because
in the in nature they live in the soil
they live like underground so
if they can they would just dig into the
soil and disappear and we can't watch
them of course anymore
so in the plaster it's too hard to dig
but it's nice for the ants they like it
because it's moist and they're very
happy
and so now stephanie is taking some of
these
these food items and she's putting them
inside the nest
and now you can see that some of the
ants are coming and they're all excited
and they're bringing the food items back
to the nest and here you can almost see
like a little trail of ants that goes
back to the nest
here you see them now sit on on all the
food and you can see some of them they
carry larvae around
some of them carry their own larvae and
some of them carry food items so now
they're
starting to feed their own baby larvae
so that's kind of how we keep them
inside that and how we feed them
so now to make a dictionary that allows
us to translate and pheromone language
into english say
we first want to figure out what the
chemicals the ants use actually are
and to do this we extract chemicals from
different parts of the ants
so for example the head or the the butt
or
different legs or sometimes you can even
dissect out some of these glands and
then extract chemicals directly from
them
and then we when we've extracted some
chemicals we put them
on a complicated machine it's called a
gas
it's called gas chromatography mass
spectrometry i mean that's kind of a
mouthful so we usually just say gcms
and um in this machine we can inject our
ant extract into a stream of gas that
comes out of this kind of
bottle here um and this
then we inject them here and then our
chemicals pass
over this really long column and you can
see that it's kind of coiled here so
it's a really really long column
and some chemicals they go through this
column very quickly and others
take longer and that's a great way to
separate all the different chemicals
that come from an
ant and because we already know for many
chemicals how long they take to go
through this column
uh knowing how long each chemical from
the ants takes
already gives us a lot of information
about what these chemicals might be
but once the chemicals come out of this
column and are separated
we can then look at some of the other
properties with this other machine
called the mass spectrometer
and so then in the end we get a graph
that looks something like this and every
peak
is a different chemical that came from
one of our ants
and the peaks that are that on the left
are the ones that took less time to go
through the column and the peaks on the
right
are those that took more time and here
the higher the peaks are
the more of the chemical we got out of
the end
and of course we also know where in the
end each chemical came from so here for
example the red peaks are chemicals that
came from the ants head
and the blue peaks are chemicals that
came from the and spot
and from these peaks and some of the
other data we get from this machine we
can learn which chemicals the ants have
in different glands
in different parts of their body and so
now we know what the possible words are
that the ants are using but we don't of
course yet know what they mean in ant
language
and so the next step then is to assign
meaning to each of these chemicals
so now for example imagine that an ant
comes to the nest
and wants to say alarm something really
dangerous is happening and we have to
get out of here
so which chemical is she using and the
way we figure this out
is that we design behavioral experiments
in which we expose the ants to different
chemicals we have identified and then we
see whether they react
as if someone has just shouted along all
right
and so now i'm going to show you a video
of another researcher in the lab lindsey
who's our ant whisperer and who is doing
exactly such an experiment
and so here's lindsay and she's bringing
some more little nests with ants
here they are but now you can see that
they look a little bit different from
the ones i showed you before
and here each nest has two chambers and
they are connected by a little tunnel
and so the ants they they have their
little nest
the little cluster in one of those
chambers
and then lindsay can give them different
chemicals and see whether that's enough
to cause an alarm response
to cause the ants to move into the other
chamber and get kind of freaked out so
here you can see the chamber and now
lindsay puts them
under microscope so she can watch them
and also take a little video of the
experiment
here are the ants see they're all on the
right side almost all one is kind of
looking around on the left side but the
nest
is up in the top left corner on the
right side of the arena
so they're all kind of quiet and relaxed
inside the nest and here comes lindsay
and she takes some chemical out of this
little
bile with a syringe
and then she puts it on a piece of paper
and now she wants to see whether this
chemical causes the ants to freak out
whether this chemical might mean
alarm we have to get out of here so she
takes this little piece of paper with
the chemical on it
with the forceps
and now she puts it inside the ant nest
on the side where the ants can't touch
it but they can smell it and you can see
that all the ants get freaked out and
they
try to run into the other side of the of
the nest chamber just as if lindsey had
shouted alarm in ant language
and so now i've shown you how the ant
shot alarm but of course that's only one
of the many things the ants want to
communicate
and you know some things you want to say
are a bit more complicated than just
shouting alarm
and so for example how does an aunt tell
the other ants that she has fond food
and that they should go outside and get
it and of course she also has to tell
where the food is not only that there is
food and when things get more
complicated you have to use more words
to communicate them
but as i'll show you in this video even
here our ants can achieve the task with
only two different pheromones
so i already told you that in nature our
ants attack the colonies of other types
of ants to steal their brood their
larvae and their pupae
and so they do this um by sending out
what we call scout ants and here's one
it's b y so it's blue yellow that's the
two dots on its back
and she's exploring the forging arena
the nest where all the ants are sitting
and tending to their own brood that's in
the lower right corner and now she's
found a food item
this is a pupa from a different ant
species from a fire ant that we have
injected with blue dye so you can see it
better
and now she's she's checking it out and
she's getting excited she thinks it's a
good
food item and she's walking back to her
nest and she's laying a trail with
another pheromone a trail pheromone
which you can't see but you'll see in a
minute
and now she goes inside the nest and she
uses another pheromone to tell the ants
that they have to go outside and follow
the pheromone trail
and that's what they're doing they're
running along the pheromone trail of the
of the first ant and they're finding the
food
so that's a pretty complex behavior
right the the ant had to tell them
where the food is and they had to tell
she had to tell the other ants to
go and find the food
so the trail pheromone tells the other
ants where the food is and the
recruitment pheromone somehow tells them
to go look for the pheromone trail
but the recruitment pheromone could mean
at least two slightly different things
so it could mean go out of the nest and
you'll find my pheromone trail
of course but it could also mean come
here where i
where i am and you'll find my pheromone
trail so those are very similar things
to say but they mean slightly different
things
and so in the experiment i just showed
you this would look the same
because in each case the ants would run
toward the exit which is where the ant
that just came home is
but to understand what the ants are
saying even better we have to do more
experiments of course
and so here we build a nest with a
little fence in the middle
and the ants can still smell the
pheromones through the fence
but they can't cross the fence and so
now if an ant comes back and says
go out of the nest and you'll find my
pheromone trail then what we would
expect is that the ants on both sides of
the fence
should leave the nest and the ones on
the left side they should go through the
left tunnel
and the ones on the right side they
should go through the right tunnel
but if the ant comes back and in fact is
saying come here where i
am and you'll find my pheromone trail
then the response should be very
different the ants on the right will go
out through the tunnel
on the right side and they'll find the
trail because that's where the ant that
came back is
but the ants on the left they will run
into the fence instead because they are
trying to get to the ant that is saying
come here
right and so now we can use this
experiment to test which one of these
hypotheses is correct
and i'll show you the brute the prey
item is again here this time we forgot
to dye it so you can't see it that well
unfortunately but you just have to
believe me and now this ant is finding
it
the prey item is white you can see it a
little bit but not very well
she gets excited again and she walks
back
and she goes inside her nest chamber and
what happens the ants run out
and they find the trail but what do the
ants on this side do
just in case you didn't pay attention
i'll play it again
but this time only look at the ants on
the left side i know most on the action
of the action is happening on the right
side but
what's really interesting what's
happened with the ants on the left side
so again the ant comes
finds the prey item
now she's touching it with her antennae
because she's smelling
what the prey item is and now she's
getting excited she knows it's a piece
of amp root and she's running back but
now look at the ants on the left side
not on the right side what are they
doing
they run into the fence do you see that
they run into the fence the moment the
ant the scout ant comes back into the
nest
so clearly what the scout end is saying
is come here where i
am and you'll find my pheromone trail
and so with these kind of additional
experiments we can
understand better and better what the
ants are saying with which pheromone
trail
with which pheromones and which
chemicals
so i've shown you that like humans the
ants are really good at working together
but instead of speaking with words the
ants they communicate with pheromones
instead
and so i've shown you how we can use
chemistry experiments to figure out what
these pheromones are
and i've shown you also how we use
behavior experiments to figure out what
these pheromones actually mean
and so with that i'll say enjoy science
saturday and
if you have any questions about ants
that you want to ask me i'll be happy
and try to answer them
thank you awesome thank danielle thank
you so much for your fascinating
presentation
you've opened our eyes to the wonders of
ant colonies and sparked
a lot of interesting questions they've
really been coming in when we have a ton
of questions also that we received
um throughout the week when people were
registering so we've allowed
about 25 to 30 minutes for questions
which is a long time and so i hope to
get to all of yours
and we will do our best to do that uh if
again if you want to ask a question
please use the q
a function at the bottom of your screen
to type in your question
all right um that let's see there are so
many awesome
uh questions um okay how about this one
what is an aunt's favorite food
it's very different for different ant
species
so our clone raider ants for example as
i already told you they
hunt other ant species and then they eat
the brood of those ant species but not
all ants are like that some ants
they feed for example on nectar from
flowers or
other parts of trees some ants that you
can see here even they feed on
the poop of aphids actually so aphids
are insects that
they sit on plants and they suck uh the
sap from the plants
and the plant sap is very sugar rich and
so the aphids have to
drink a lot of it to get any kind of
other nutrients like amino acids for
example or nitrogen
so they drink a lot much more that they
that they need in terms of just the
liquid
and the sugar so it's a little bit like
lemonade and they poop it back out and
then the ants come
and eat that it's a bit disgusting but
the ants like it because it's sweet
um then there's even other ants like for
example the famous leaf cutting ants
that also live in places like costa rica
or even in the southern united states
and those actually they cut leaves but
they don't eat the leaves they bring the
leaves back to the nest
but then they use the leaves to
cultivate a fungus garden
so they are kind of they're like farmers
they're fungus farmers and then the leaf
cutting ants
they only eat the fungus so the fungus
needs the leaves and
the and the leaf cutting ants they eat
the fungus
species eat very different things a lot
of them are scavengers they walk around
and they look for dead insects
and they eat those mostly um
so you know it really depends on the ant
species
what they eat but that's also part of
why ants are so important in ecosystems
because
um they just have a very important role
in like
eating dead animals for example and
removing carcasses
and these kind of things wow i had no
idea that they played such a significant
role and had such a varied diet that's
really incredible
um we had a couple of other questions
around
uh ideas around how
fast ants move and escaping and i i
noticed in the video
that when um the ants were being fed
um the scientists went into a a sort of
like
special door to access the ant colonies
um can you tell us a little bit more
about
like whether or not ants can escape or
why you have this store and also do they
escape your tupperware
like how does that all play in yeah so
we have to be super careful that our
ants don't escape there's actually a lot
of
regulations because if you um you know
if you want to keep
ants at home you can always collect ants
from your backyard or the forest in new
york but if you
and that's fine you can keep those at
home but if you want to
keep ants that are not in new york then
you have to get special permits which
probably you won't get but i got and so
we can go to other places in the world
and we can get ants from there so the
species that we work with this colonel
raider and
they actually occur on tropical islands
mostly so we collected them for example
in on caribbean islands
on islands in asia and then we bring
when we bring those kind of ants back
then
of course people are a little bit
worried that they might escape and we
don't want that
and then so there's like special
regulations on how we have to keep them
and that's why we have them in the
in the room that's locked and we have
them in these like very high tupperware
boxes and then the tupperware boxes are
on shelves
um and there's kind of you know all
kinds of precautions that even if they
get out of the tupperware box they can't
get off the shelf and even if they would
get off the shelves they can't get off
out of the room and so there's many
layers of and security so it's like a
high security prison for us
but we try to make it nice for them it's
a nice place yeah yeah
um yeah they get good outdoor time
some gym time you know the rooms where
they are in they have to be
a certain temperature and they have to
have high humidity because the ants want
to feel at home so they want to feel
like they're in the tropics
and so right it's always nice and cozy
so we had some questions you know you
say you know the ants in
in your lab want to feel like they're in
the tropics but are there ants
ants are everywhere right so is there a
region
that has more ants uh the most
ants for example like some of the
questions or was there a country for
example that might have the most species
of ants
inside of it yeah the most ants like in
many
types of animals and plants the most the
highest diversity of ants is
actually in the tropics so if you go to
like a tropical rainforest there's
there's a ton of ants different so in
this place in costa rica where we did a
lot of our field work
um there's been a pretty good survey of
somebody who
tried to really find all the ants that
are there and they found over 400
different types of ants
and so that's that's pretty amazing um
but even here in you know in north
america
like um if you go somewhere
in a forest or upstate somewhere a
little bit out of the city
um you can find a few dozen ants
different types of ants in
a forest like that so there's just a lot
of ants and ants are pretty much
everywhere in at least in like on land
of course they know ants in water but
they are on all continents but
antarctica antarctica has no ants it's
to cold fronts but
every other place really has ants cool
and also actually maybe i should add
that ants are very good at
um they become invasive which is a
little bit of a problem maybe you've
heard of fire ants for example that
are now like in in the southern us
in florida for example and they kind of
stings that are a little bit nasty they
originally come from argentina but then
humans brought them inadvertently they
didn't mean to bring them over but
it happened they kind of traveled on
ships or something and so some ant
species they tend to travel
around the world so for example some
islands that are kind of really remote
like hawaii
there weren't any ants because ants
couldn't get there
but then since people started to you
know travel back and forth between
hawaii and the mainland and so on
now there's actually a lot of ants on
hawaii i think there's maybe something
like 60 different ant species on hawaii
but none of them came from hawaii
originally they were all brought by
humans
so especially now with humans traveling
everywhere
like ants all over yes right it's a
global
uh ant civilization i suppose now
because of us
um so sp you mentioned fire ants and we
did get a question so fire ants do they
sting
or they or do they bite oh they're worse
they do both
they do oh goodness yeah i know i i've
been told to steer clear of
them when i travel down to the south
yeah what they do is first they kind of
they bite and then they use that as kind
of leverage to drive in this stinger and
that basically oh my goodness
they're brutal so are there other
species of ants that sting or bite
um because you know the the ants that i
see in in
sort of like on campus or like you know
on the street they're they seem so
gentle and
friendly you know yeah like most ants if
you you know if you don't annoy them
they're not going to bite you like even
the fire ants right they bite you
if you or sting you if you step on their
anthill
and they don't just come to your house
to sting you but they don't
have no interest in that but for example
the army ants that we study in costa
rica they are also like that they bite
and they sting
and so you know as long as we leave them
alone that's that's fine but
of course we can because we want to
study them so we have to get really
close
and and you know like kind of look
what's inside the colony a little bit
and and then you always get a few on
your arms and
up your pants and your legs and then
they start fighting stinging you oh my
goodness
have you ever been bitten by uh army
ants or fire ants
oh many times and you made it
you're fine yeah um
it's not that bad it's only you know
like some ants uh
it's only a problem if you're allergic
otherwise you know you just have five
minutes
it's uncomfortable but you'll get
through it yeah
you don't want to get stuck with like
thousands of ants but if not right
it's not a big deal now some of these
ants are
should i tell you what the worst dance
thing is sure actually let's go there
let's do it yeah
the sting of the bullet ant okay really
big and
it also lives in costa rica actually and
that and it's
it's actually called bullet and because
the sting
hurts like like you kind of you got shot
with the bullet
that's right they're also called 24-hour
ants because the pain
lasts stays for 24 well geez i actually
think it's exaggerated i got stung i
think twice
and i mean it's not nice don't try it if
you don't have to but it's not
it's not that bad right so how many
species
of ants have you been stung by or bitten
by
i don't know too many to count
i don't i don't keep a species stung
list yeah
well 20 30.
wow that's incredible that's really
incredible
cool that was a problem like if you get
kind of close then
you know and then they get annoyed you
kind of you look at the colony and you
try to find the queen or something and
then
right right you can't figure out what's
going on yeah i don't really get out of
here human
yeah yeah but usually i don't i don't
mind if you're like excited enough
that you've seen that you found like an
ant colony then you know you can take a
sting or two
cool yeah so okay so these ants they're
like
they seem a lot of them are super armed
right but we also know that ants are
super strong and a lot of questions from
our audience are wondering
what makes an ant so strong and even you
mentioned it before
that they have this you know that you
can just shove them under this sort of
nylon thread and start painting them and
they won't feel a thing
that's just fascinating yeah so the the
thing with the nylon thread
that works because the ants don't like
you know like
we have our skeletons inside of us with
like the bones
and everything and then the muscles and
everything else is like on the on the
outside
so we're kind of soft and with the ants
it's the other way around or insects in
general where they have like in what's
called an exoskeleton so the hard part
is on the outside
and then all the soft part is inside and
attaches to the to the heart outer part
and so that's why the ants are just
really hard and they don't mind
you know if you like squish them a
little bit um
and our ants are especially hard because
they're good at fighting they're like
these little tanks that go into the
colonies of other ant species and then
they plunder
uh the other ant colonies and so they
have to be really
robust to being attacked but there's
also another reason why the ants are so
strong because you know they're only
strong relative to how small they are of
course
right like i mean an ad can't lift i
don't know
like this table behind like my bottle of
water
yeah and so um
i mean the explanation is a little bit
more kind of physics almost right so the
as animals get a lot like ants are
really small right but as animals get
larger
the mass of an animal or like how much
the the animal weighs
kind of um well it's kind of a cubic
function
but the surface area or like and that's
kind of correlated with the strength of
the animal more like the
the muscle surface area that's like a
squared function
so the the mass increases much faster
than the
the strength of an animal and that's for
example you know what like an insect can
walk on the ceiling upside down that's
nothing for an insect they can even do
that by carrying something
and a human already has a little bit of
a hard time you know like doing the
monkey bars or like
hanging on the ceiling and then if you
put weight on it it gets like really
tough
but now imagine like an elephant trying
to do the monkey bars right that's
going to happen so small things are just
really strong
relative to their body size right
but now you know like in horror movies
you sometimes see these like ants that
are massive
and they're super strong but that's not
how it works like if you took like a
tiny ant and you just scaled it up to
the size of a human
it wouldn't be much stronger than us
either right because it has done the
same
it has the same problem well i guess
it's good that people are creative in
their imagination
sometimes it's helpful to to think
outside the ground but it's also
very nice to know that
it's unlikely for a giant ant to be
stronger than us just in case that
occasion ever arose um the problem is
that there would still be so many right
right i guess there's like other things
to worry about
right yeah different strategies so
we have this great question from
alexandra who wonders
how you know you talk about ant
pheromones and that you know the scout
comes back and delivers the
pheromones but how do the ants in the
nest receive the pheromone
like how do they hear the words at the
front of the head you can actually see
this in this big picture i put up here
this is a really really big
picture of one of our clone raider hands
so the antenna is here
see this and here's the other one and so
on the antenna you can even see this a
little bit they have like little hairs
and inside the hairs they're like nerve
cells and those nerve cells they
they they respond when they're hit with
a with a chemical with a pheromone
and different cells they respond to
different types of pheromones so
different chemicals and then
there's a there's an electrical signal
like a like the signal from the neuron
that
then gets transferred to the brain and
then the ant registers oh
one of these chemicals hit my antenna
and that's kind of how they smell
so it's a little bit like we smell with
our nose it's kind of the same principle
almost
and we have a ton of questions around
how long do ants live
oh that's another really good question
so you know it's also something i didn't
really
talk much about too much but the ants in
ants they're like
there's kind of two different types of
well there's three different types of
ants they're male ants
the male ants don't live very long you
hardly ever see them sometimes in the
spring
they have like wings and then they come
out and they fly they go on a mating
flight but then they die
like all the ants you see like on the
sidewalk or you know when they come into
your house and eat your sugar
those are all female ants and those are
worker ants
so they're two types of female ants the
workers that's the ants that you see all
the time
and then they are the queens and the
queens are the ones that that lay all
the eggs and the workers do all the rest
the queens only lay eggs they don't do
anything else and so
and the queens they mate with the male
ants in the spring and the males die but
the queens survive
and so the ant colony kind of
dies when the queen dies usually and so
there's a really
really interesting and really striking
difference between how long worker ants
live
and how long queen's queen ants live so
you know in
in some species where this is known the
worker ants live maybe for
you know like four weeks or eight weeks
like a couple of months or so they don't
live very long
sometimes they live like half a year or
so but they never live like super long
but the queen ants they can sometimes
live for like 20 or even 30 years
so you have kind of they're both ants
but one that's very short
like most insects actually and then one
lives super long
like for an insect living for 30 years
that's almost unheard of
that's incredible people are actually
very interested in figuring out how that
works right because if you maybe
yeah you know you can figure out why a
queen ant can live so long maybe you can
make humans live longer if that's
something yeah we're always
looking uh yeah the fountain of youth
you know
so i i love this question um because we
learned so much already about how many
ants you've been
bitten or stung by i think it's worth
knowing uh
what is your favorite ant species and
why
oh oh that's hard there's so many hat
species
that i really like my favorite ants i
have to say my favorite ant species are
the army ants just because
well those are the ones that i've spent
a lot of time with
and um they just have really really big
colonies
and they just i think they just do the
coolest stuff like for example building
this
ant house the ant colony like out of the
ant bodies themselves
only army ants can do that um and they
also do other cool stuff they build like
bridges
out of their own bodies and then other
ants like travel over the bridges
wow and um all kinds of cool stuff i
could have
spent the whole day just talking about
army lands i think those are the those
are my favorite nights still
cool it kind of reminds me you ever see
that movie big hero 6
when sort of little micro machines like
come together
to like build things and they move
together i don't know if anybody's ever
seen that movie but
so that's this is something that um you
know there's some some colleagues of
mine that also work on
ants but they're more they're actually
more they work on robotics
but they get a lot of inspiration from
from how the ants behave
to then design like robot swarms which
is kind of
what you meant genie right like that's
yeah yeah yeah i'm very interested in
that because you can
you know they want to basically have
like really simple robots like the ants
like really simple individual
units right but then they follow like
simple rules like the ants follow
pretty simple rules but then if you
program the robots correctly
you can get pretty complex you can get
them to solve pretty complex tasks
so for example people are trying to make
robots that could go
um like if a house collapses for example
you could send like a robot swarm in and
they collectively then find
where people might be under the
something so like
to rescue people for example wow
that that's um that's a really useful so
studying ants seem to have
a variety of applications that spin
things that are just outside of ant
biology right i mean a lot of the things
that
people are learning from ants can be
applied elsewhere
i mean do we see a direct relationship
between what you're learning
it with your ant studies with how we
might think about human
um behavior or human biology of any kind
yeah of course like you know i mean
that's uh
like all of life is connected right like
all life forms
use kind of the same molecules and and
have like a few principles how life is
just organized right and so
you know you can use species like fruit
flies for example and learn something
about how life in general works and
because humans are also part of life
you can also learn something about how
we work right and it's the same with the
ants
and uh so you know yeah there's like
a lot of applications like that maybe go
a little bit beyond that even like the
robot swarms we discussed but then the
you know these questions about longevity
for example with the
screens that live for so long um we are
also very interested in just
understanding how
social behavior works right like the the
ants are very social
and as i've shown you today they talk
with pheromones but
um for example they take really good
care of their of their larvae of their
babies so to say where they feed them
and they
clean them and um most insects don't do
that most insects they just lay an egg
somewhere and then
they're off right and the offspring is
by themselves but enhances is very
different like the ants
really care for the offspring they have
like very sophisticated and complex
uh brute care behavior and mammals of
course do that too right like mammals
look after their babies and
and feed them and so on so on and and so
you know these are like some
of these kind of social behaviors that
now we can study in ants and
maybe see how they're regulated and
maybe can tell us something about how
mammals do that kind of stuff
including humans right cool but mostly
you know
i really like ants yeah for me these are
kind of almost sex
thoughts
i understand yeah yeah
they're the questions for for others who
might need to know
you know um for various reasons but
we have this wonderful question from
arjun who wants to know
about how queen ants arise are they born
or
do they change into queens from workers
or how does that work
yeah dick you kind of in most species
you're kind of born as a queen
and so the way it works is that um you
know at the when
when an egg is late or like this there's
just an egg
right so at the egg stage you don't know
yet whether that egg is ultimately going
to become a worker or queen
but then from the egg hatches a larva so
that the larva of a queen of an ant is a
little bit like a caterpillar
in butterflies right it's kind of the
same developmental stage
and then it depends on things like how
much the
lava gets to eat and how the larvae is
treated
and and then the lava can get very large
or it can get pretty small stay pretty
small right and then it enters
metamorphosis
so again like the caterpillar it becomes
like chrysalis and the ant we call it
the pupa
and then the question is when the ant
becomes the larva becomes the
the pupa is it large is it small and if
it's very large and has gotten a lot of
good food
then it's going to become a queen and if
it's very small because it didn't eat
that much
then it's going to become a worker
that's kind of
very basically how it works but yeah
it's not
it's it's decided during childhood
and childhood what do you want to call
it cool
um there was another question that we
you i just want to
jump back to um talking about how you
said that there were ants everywhere
except antarctica ants on every
continent except antarctica
and i i mean there's certainly ants
around here in new york but we have a
winter
what happens to the ants during the
winter how do they survive
so they over winter they they kind of
usually they
they dig down a little bit further into
the soil and then they're just kind of
deep in the soil
where it doesn't get like super cold i
mean it just gets cold but
it doesn't get it doesn't kill them and
then they just don't move very much
and they wait until it warms up again
and when it warms up again they move
everything up again that's why in the
spring often you can it's actually
spring is a great time to to find ants
and collect
ant colonies because you can you can
flip over rocks
and sometimes because the ants want to
warm up they sit right under the rock
because the sun shines on the rock and
then it gets kind of nice and
warm under there and it's kind of almost
the best time to find ants around here
yeah i i was i had um i was really lucky
to travel with the member of your team
to go looking for ants under rocks in
the forest
two years ago it was super cool and we
found several species of ants and we
brought them back to the lab and we set
up our own ant colonies and
it was so cool to participate in a
process like that so anybody can do it
um how many places have you been
uh you know how many where have you
visited for studying games like how many
places this is
presumably taking you to some really
neat spots
uh across the globe proof
how many yeah or maybe if you can't
think of how many maybe you can tell us
maybe one or two of the coolest places
you've ever been um
so i did um when i actually when i first
started working on ants i worked
in the southern us and arizona and new
mexico
i was still living in germany but i did
my field work there because they're
they're cool ants that are they're
called
honeypot ants they're called honeypot
ants because they
um they some of the workers they eat so
much that they get all like blown up
and then they can't move anymore and
then the ants just take them and they
they stick them to the ceiling of the
nest
and then they hang like little honey
pots and then when the going gets rough
then they can
they can spit some of the food back up
and then the other ends
they have kind of like storage
containers hanging from the ceiling and
both events i studied early on so i was
a lot in new mexico and in arizona and
then
i worked a lot in venezuela because then
that's when i started to work on homie
and some army hands are
in tropical areas so then i did a lot of
work in venezuela
and also in kenya in africa
and i also did then some work in kansas
actually because
the army ants they come they come north
as
as high up as kind of about kansas
that's kind of the northern
edge of their range and there's some
kind of cool biology going up
as it gets going on as it gets colder so
i spent like a few weeks in kansas
in the console prairie in manhattan
actually
there's two manhattan manhattan kansas
i collected up there for a while yeah um
and then more recently
we spent a lot of time in uh working in
costa rica
on hand since i came to rockefeller we
spent like
like over four years or so me and a
postdoc went to costa rica every year
like hard work oh and once we have the
lab now
i said already i collected them in japan
um and in the us virgin islands in the
caribbean
cool so and so science has taken you all
over the world
one another really neat benefit of
getting into
into this type of work and field work in
particular
um so you know i think you know we
showed a bunch of pictures of your lab
but you do a lot of field work like
maybe we can explain to the audience
really quickly before we
uh wrap things up like what what is the
difference between the laboratory
work and the field work that you do
um so you know in the in
the laboratory work the nice thing about
the laboratory is that you can really
you can control everything right like we
can we know what the temperature is and
we know how many hands on the colony and
we know what they've been eating
and you know we know everything
almost everything right and then we can
you know we can change one thing at a
time and we can see how it changes for
example how the ants behave
and then it's much easier to say that
because i changed this one thing
this is what caused the ants to to
behave differently but
so you can it's easier to establish
these kind of links
in the field everything is a little bit
more complicated because the ants just
do what they're doing
and it's more it's trickier to get kind
of a good
handle on manipulating the colony and
experiments
um but on the other hand when you're in
the field yeah
you you see what the ants are really
doing right and you get maybe sometimes
a better feeling for why they're doing
the things they're doing
because you you're there to see why
they're doing it right versus in the lab
it's a little bit abstract
right like sometimes they do something
which maybe makes sense in the rain
forest in costa rica or
in in the woods in upstate new york but
in the lab it just looks like it doesn't
make any sense and then it's a little
bit harder to
interpret so for us this like back and
forth is really helpful because we can
we can do work in the field we get some
inspiration we learn something about
what we think why the ants are doing
something in a particular way and then
we can really test things more
targeted in the lab and also things that
we learn in the lab
that you can't really learn that well in
the field but then once we have learned
it and we kind of know what we're
looking for we can go back in the field
and do a much more targeted experiment
and then you know it's more likely that
it's going to work
right it seems like a yeah a really good
system
that sort of helps you learn the big
picture
um so we're nearing the end which is
such a bummer because i love science
saturday so much
but i want to ask one last question and
this one really intrigues me because i
had never heard of it
um we have a question that asks um what
are your thoughts on the dinosaur and
um is there such a an ant and that
sounds fascinating can you tell us about
it
do you know what um
i i'm not sure which ant you mean by
dinosaur and
they said uh notho miranda
am i saying that right oh yeah that's a
that's a specialist
[Laughter]
um what are my thoughts on that so
that's a
um that's a species that people have
been
talking about kind of like one of these
living
fossils which is not really a thing
right like
fossils are not living but it's it's a
species that oh it's
not something messiah is a genus but
it's really only
i think one species in a genus and they
they look like very ancient ants and so
they have they're kind of a little bit
maybe primitive in some ways socially
like they they don't have very big
colonies and
and um so people
some and there's some there's a few
species like that where like people
think that they can maybe
they resemble what ants looked like when
they first evolved right and
and then people think that maybe from
studying these species we can learn
something about these early ants
and um you know i think to some
extent that's probably true but for
north america for example we know that
they are actually not
they kind of it gets a little bit
technically but now evolutionary
speaking they're kind of nested very
deeply within
the ant evolutionary tree of life right
they're not
they're not like distantly related to
the other ants there's like there's like
two
groups of ants that are kind of that are
still alive and that they're distantly
related to the
to other ants so so those might be even
more informative and then of course
there are fossils and
it turns out that ants actually um
when ants first originated that was kind
of at the height of the dinosaur so like
about 100 million years ago
and we have actually fossils from from
back then and some of them look
completely crazy there's some
completely crazy uh jaws that
kind of trapped animals like not like
this this way i showed you this one trap
joint but they have like
some of them have jaws that go like this
and um
like little crocodiles yeah like really
strange
stuff and those ants are extinct and
they're not even
they're very distantly related to the to
the ancestral life today
i had never even considered ant fossils
um and now i'm going to be googling that
for the after they're beautiful because
insects
are preserved in amber and so you get
these like amber peas
that have like a really nice preserved
ant in there and then they're like 100
million years so i can actually show you
one really quick
cool yeah please show you two things so
this is an amber fossil
this is actually from can you see this
yes
one of my former students next to me
this is a species that it's about
yeah like 100 million years old or
something you can't see
well and this here is the largest ant in
the world
this is the queen of an african army ant
can you see her
like this one thing she's she's over two
inches long
that's the biggest ant that's out there
holy cow and that answers the question i
think there was a bunch of questions of
what the biggest
and that's what we were getting toward
with the i thought it would be the
dinosaur ant but
here we are with the queen army ant so
cool
your favorite and of course all right
folks well
this has been so much fun it has been
daniel thank you for your fascinating
presentation
uh you really opened our eyes to the
wonders of ant colonies
um and also just
wow i'm gonna google all of this stuff
ants are just super beautiful
so thanks to everyone for taking your
time on a saturday afternoon to explore
science
at rockefeller and for asking terrific
questions
we had so many questions i'm sorry we
weren't able to get to everything but
we're gonna see what we can do after
this maybe we can answer them later on
um but before you go i have some
important announcements
on the sign saturday website you'll find
fun activities that
uh rocky to you made that are related to
ants that you can do at home and this
includes
things like coloring pages um we worked
with
a bunch of really cool artists to
generate this for you um
and the link for this will be on the
closing slide we are especially grateful
for the andreas c drakopolis family
science and society initiative for their
generous support of two
of rockefeller science outreach programs
science saturday
and talking science which is a program
for high school students offered in
january
so thanks again for joining us happy
science saturday
and we hope to see you next year on
campus for next year science saturday on
may 7
2022 okay we'll see you soon
[Music]
you